the more i think about it after letting
the finale set
in and after reading all the comments
you guys left on my last video
it really was impressive how much they
set up early in the season
and paid it all off in the gray they're
writing this series always looking
forward
and they're ending each season super
strong hey guys pete here
this is my for all mankind season three
questions and predictions video
of course we're going to talk about
everything that's happened through
seasons one and two so if you haven't
seen
those yet this is your spoiler warning
and your chance to leave because we're
gonna jump right in
with the nature of the ripple effects in
the alternate timeline
it's pretty hard to craft an overall
prediction that imagines the complete
trajectory for season three
the big question on everyone's mind is
what was going on
in that last shot on mars and what that
means for season three
and of course i will finish this video
off discussing that
but that's still a decade down the road
there's a lot of room for major
divergences to unfold in that amount of
time
think about all the things we learned
about happening between the seasons
and the first episode montage in season
two
to kick things off the first question
that comes to mind for me
is what the actual fallout will be for
the events of the finale
how will those events affect things
globally and what does it mean for this
never ending space race the show set up
in the short
term world war 3 has been averted you
would think that this would translate to
electoral strength
and a presidential victory for reagan's
republican party
in the upcoming election in 1984.
remember in the show he was elected in
1976
so his second term is coming to an end
that makes me think that the next
president will be his vice president
in the show which is actually richard
schweiker instead of
george h.w bush either way the ending
that we got
is a temporary reprieve but not the end
of the cold war and maybe not the space
race
either i mean both leaders were looking
for a way out of a nuclear showdown
and we're happy to get it in the way of
apollo soyuz
but it definitely doesn't undo all the
stuff that got us to that point
as i said it's a reprieve but there's
still serious underlying tensions
the reason why space travel is advancing
in this alternate timeline is
the rivalry if you take that away how do
you justify the ongoing spending
to continue to explore space if either
side bows out
you have to imagine that things would
start to look more like the timeline we
live in
and at this point the soviets are still
kind of winning only things are shifting
a little
since now the us does have the working
nerva engine and pathfinder
they're still looking for something to
be that big thing they did
first though i mean if you don't count
shooting and killing someone on the moon
first
and i don't think anything that happened
in season 2 would be the thing that
slows them down
plus we already know someone will be
pushing to get to mars
and it will just be a question of who
the real
end of the cold war is essentially in
1989 in our timeline
and that means we'll go past that before
season three starts
does that mean the dissolution of the
ussr will have happened by the early 90s
or do the changes the shows made mean
that it'll still be there
it's really hard to say because there
are differences
and the show's not above hand waving
certain things
and to be honest it doesn't feel like
they're going anywhere at the end of
season two
there weren't big hints that they were
starting to crumble from the inside
so most of that actually comes from what
happened in our timeline
i guess the main things to think about
is that the show is definitely shifting
away from
the quagmires that happened in the
middle east the ussr didn't go into
afghanistan they're not tied up there
also three mile island didn't happen in
the u.s
and that's an indication that chernobyl
might not happen in the soviet union
either
the next big question is what will the
core group of characters that are still
alive going to be doing in the mid 90s
their ages are going to start being
important for reference
ed will be in his early 60s and from
there you can kind of put everyone
else's ages into perspective
and speaking of ed are karen and ed
still together
will they still be together in season
three i've seen a lot of comments
pointing out that they were in two
separate cars at the funeral
if they were in houston that wouldn't
seem so out of place
but they were at arlington national
cemetery and that makes me think there
may be something to it
the writers may have given us that to
show that they're
separated we know that they split up
before and came back together in the
process
of adopting kelly i definitely think
they have problems ahead in their
marriage
but honestly given the 10-year gap their
marriage and what happens there
isn't really that interesting to me at
this point i'd like to see ed pass the
torch
he could certainly still play a crucial
role at nasa but he's pretty much
cemented his legacy at this point
and the younger characters are going to
have to start stepping into the main
roles
it'll be curious to see what they do
with karen now she doesn't own the bar
anymore
of course kelly is probably gonna be
that connection
they're gonna have to give karen
something else to do to keep her
involved in season three
sort of like how they gave her the
outpost in season two
molly cobb is another big question mark
as far as the old astronauts are
concerned
she's going blind and that may be the
least of her worries when you think
about it there could also be cancer or
other complications coming to her
in the future because of her exposure to
the radiation on the surface of the moon
she's a great character just like ed i
hope she's still involved
but with each decade we skip ahead it's
harder to see where their stories are
leading
i think it's safe to say that danny and
margo will probably still be involved in
high-ranking positions at nasa
but you also have to believe that danny
will actually
achieve real worldwide celebrity status
after apollo soyuz
it's one of those things that gets
burned into the collective psyche of
humanity so everyone's gonna know who
she was and what she did
it's kind of hard to imagine margot
doing anything else besides what she's
always been
doing she's a workaholic she's dedicated
to the space
program she's dedicated to nasa and of
course
they definitely set up a situation where
she may end up
compromised sergey definitely did reach
out to her
after the funeral because soviet
intelligence wanted him to
the question there is when did they
start to come after him to get to her
like i said in the finale breakdown i
tend to think that they had real
chemistry
so to me it makes the most sense that
she gave him the information about the
o-rings
he went and took care of that and at
that point they realized that they had
something they could hold over her head
sergey where's a wedding band he seems
to have a wife back in the soviet union
so it's in the realm of possibility that
it was always set up that way
if you think back to when she gave him
the note to meet her at the bar
it was a little bit surprising that he
was able to shake his handlers
and show up there alone he also asked
her questions like is this a secret
place for you
and you can make an argument that he was
always on that path
and i guess in the big picture it
doesn't matter beyond the fact that if
the chemistry was real
and they use that against him he's gonna
be more sympathetic
and that might come in handy for her if
things get crazy
i can't say that her being a willing
participant to pass state secrets makes
a whole lot of sense
which means it seems more like a setup
for something that'll tank her career
i think one of the most interesting
characters to wonder about
is ellen there was that whole lee
atwater scene
throwing out the idea of her becoming a
politician
which definitely does seem plausible
she's the girl that caught the tank
after all
and she definitely earned some political
capital with ronald reagan
i guess the other popular idea with her
based on her father's company and her
background is that people would like to
see her go in the direction
of having her own private space company
personally i don't really like the idea
i like the way that the show took
things where nasa could make money from
their own patents and be self-sufficient
and therefore there's no need for
private corporations to get involved
with space exploration
but i suppose it does sort of all hinge
on her personal life
they've certainly made pam a big part of
her story
and she did step aside thinking that was
the right thing to do at the end of
season two
but i doubt that's the last we're gonna
see of her so the question then is well
is she more likely to pursue that and
that's how we get there
so yeah i don't really want to see ellen
go in that direction
but it seems like there's a lot of
people who do for what it's worth i
would like to see her get together with
pam
there's definitely a chance that if she
becomes a politician she'll be
successful
then there's always the chance that she
could make that public
after the fact when she already has
power so we'll just have to wait and see
as i said the new characters should be
taking over elena
is clearly in the best position to take
on an important role at mission control
in future
seasons because of her age and how young
she was in season one
she could turn out to be the only
character to feature heavily
in every season if they make the full
story that goes beyond our current
timeline
so i think it's a pretty safe guess that
she'll be the future margot
she'll take over that role after margot
gets too old or she gets pushed out
because of her situation with sergey
kelly is also following in her father's
footsteps you have to imagine that
she'll be a future astronaut
that's another safe feeling guess when
you think about it they did a lot of
personal setup for her this season
that's gonna have to pay off one way or
another
and danny could go that route too but
after the finale
and the unresolved situation with the
affair with karen
i'm wondering if he might not be set up
for a dark
turn like a real crash and burn after
his parents death
i feel like there will be a turn around
in karen's character arc
some sort of redemption and i know her
affair played a role in ed's story
as far as taking the initiative to
destroy sea dragon and thus saving the
earth but she could have had an affair
with anyone to make that happen
it feels like there has to be a reason
that they chose to make it danny
if the plan has always been just to make
him the next generation astronaut
it's not clear how the affair is a part
of that and it will kind of go down as
the one unnecessary
thing in this show that has been paying
off everything that's happened early on
i don't know how it'll play out but i
feel like this is a character defining
event for him
more so than for karen and then finally
as far as characters are concerned the
other characters that seem likely to
step up and have a bigger role in season
three
are helena webster and piscotti i think
they're both set up to come back
and be involved in the next season i
guess there's also a chance that sally
ride could be involved
i did enjoy the performance from the
actor who played her but it's a little
unclear on how she might feel about
things considering she pulled a gun
on her superior officer so the last big
thing
is mars the questions would be who won
the race to get there
all of this is influenced by all the
things i've been talking about
based on the boot that we see in the
stinger most people agree that it looks
more like the soviets
and that would be consistent they've
gotten everywhere else first
but i wouldn't say that's a slam dunk
honestly when i learned that they were
doing apollo soyuz in the show
i expected that there would be some path
that led to cooperation between the two
nations
and that might be the thing that pushed
it to mars the problem with that idea
obviously was if there's no space race
why do they go to mars anyway
but i wouldn't rule out a joint mission
and have to say that if the space race
is
still on for the next 10 years i feel
like the us would do everything that
they possibly
could to try to be the first there so if
those are cosmonauts boots
i'm gonna say that maybe they're not the
first ones to arrive
the third idea that i've seen thrown
around a lot is that
china has accelerated their space
program
and so the twist will be that they got
there first
again this is possible but it doesn't
seem that likely to me
in our timeline their first manned space
flight was 2003
by this time in history though they had
been going in a different direction
from the soviet union for quite some
time which means the show could add that
in there
that the space race continuing to go on
between the us and the soviet union
encouraged china to speed things up in
their own development
so i think that's probably enough out of
me i'm interested to hear what you guys
think there are a lot of different ideas
being thrown around
i don't think that there's that much
information in what we've seen
i don't think it's the mystery that we
can solve at this point
but it is fun to speculate on and i
think that's a good place to leave
things let me know in the comments what
you think what you're hoping to see in
season 3
any questions you have about season 2
and anything else that's on your mind as
far as this series is concerned
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon